irfan is next and he is in Houston Texas
hey your fan how are you pretty good are
you good what is your net worth sir
1.3 four million 1.34 cool and what does
that invested in sir
so about 190 in kind of liquid and the
chunk of major chunk of that is invested
about five ninety K in investments all
kinds of mutual funds structure notes um
you know index funds including you know
some correction warranted accounts 401 K
that is what IRAs - ah gotcha okay and
your age sir age 44 Oh young millionaire
very good and how much of the 1.3
million did you inherit not zero okay
and what has been your range of income
and your working lifetime sir so working
lifetime around 20 years ranged from
about 44 K to 135 K okay cool what do
you do for a living I'm a mechanical
engineer engineer oh and your degree is
in engineering and yes I'm bachelors and
a master's okay and your GPA meet me it
was 4.0 ah you're one of the smart ones
okay and the how much of the 1.3 million
is there because you borrowed money to
invest so never borrowed money to invest
I don't like that to begin with
obviously but the only time I borrow
money was to buy a home mm-hmm the plan
to pay it off as quickly as possible so
the first home I bought it off in about
six years then we had to move to Houston
and because of the timing I couldn't I
was hoping that I would never buy a
house dad because I would sell that
invite anyone but I couldn't tell at
that time side to buy and borrow money
again but this time I paid off in three
years
gotcha so now we're part has giving
played in your financial plan a major
part so we have a certain amount of
funds every year that the allocated for
sure no matter what happens and then and
then some you know has needed so mostly
people that we know are 10 no we help
out every way possible gotcha
okay
what is your accent what is your
heritage so over the born in Pakistan
uh-huh and meaning in the u.s. since 93
okay so you you came here legally
through that process and you sure you're
first-generation immigrant yes did you
know that people who come here legally
like you are four times more likely to
become millionaires than those of us
that are born here I heard something
like that that's interesting yeah and
and I think the reason is is that you
believe in America because that's why
you came here I assume absolutely nobody
put it down on my head I know because I
you know like with this time I like I
get here yeah and it worked out for you
because you worked you knew what to do
well congratulations sir you're an
economic hero I'm honored to speak with
you thank you
what is your advice to the 25 year old
version of you a first-generation
immigrant what would you tell them so
one you know it's possible to be a
millionaire it's not that hard a lot of
people think that it's all about you
know to make money and save money you
gotta make a whole lot of money what my
experience has been it's all about what
you say if not what about you what you
make and so our savings rate is 80
percent right now the only regret we
have is that if he started that journey
and we were doing it they've always been
kind of minimalist and we have become
more you know from minimalist now but
you know before we started actually
tracking money like you say you know
give every dollar a commission we do
that more religiously now if we had done
it before we are on a path to financial
independence in about four years now we
could have done it a long time ago we
just started early and you know the key
another key is like you always say you
know our bottom line and and then you
know most important thing for us is
enjoyed the journey for us is not as
much as like sacrificing and beaming
pain and and it's like a delayed
satisfaction we are you know while we
say the money we actually enjoying stuff
you never feel like we deprive we just
enjoy and we just you know we just focus
on things that are more important to us
that's how we say money yeah but we
never deprive ourselves until have a
saving rate of 80% very well said very
well done sir wow what a wonderful
testimony I love it I love it
well it's an honor to speak with you sir
very very well done okay so I talked to
folks with 2.61
point five three million two million one
point four five and one point three for
me
so no nothing lower than one point three
and nothing higher than three million
and sixty nine sixty three seventy seven
fifty one forty four and forty four that
was the millionaire's we talked to today
GPAs were all over 3.0 but most of them
were in the threes the low threes
we've had teachers we've had
businesspeople within military we've had
two engineers and let's see here one
other one oh we had a grocery store
executive and there you go I you know I
didn't hear a single athlete I didn't
hear anybody that ripped anybody off oh
by the way zero inheritance that caused
the millionaire caused the millionaire
status one guy inherited four hundred
thousand but was after he already had
over a million dollars so this this
mythology that millionaires are all evil
people and frankly it's Bernie Sanders
was putting out the message I mean
obviously he's no longer in the running
but Hillary's picked up on the message
but it's mythology you guys meaning it's
just they're freaking Liars when they
say that that you know that I'm that I'm
a little man can't get ahead and you
need to elect them in order to get ahead
it's just lying it's and they know these
numbers they know the truth I meet
millionaires like this for thirty years
I've been doing this they're all over
America there's about ten million
millionaires in America right now and
this is who they are you've been
listening to them for the last hour you
want to learn more about them check out
the new millionaire video series on our
website I mean on our YouTube page Dave
the Dave Ramsey show YouTube page it's
called millionaire and we're gonna do
deep dives and learn more about these
people so you can be like them you can
do this there was it anything special
here that you can't do you can do this
don't let any political party tell you
you can't and don't let your broke
friends tell you you can't you're not a
loser that puts this our the Dave Ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and
to walk daily with the Prince of Peace
Christ Jesus hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common